>>> A FORMER FEDERAL JUDGETE BUT
D,AIS ME
TR UEY.OM AB, NE SRISEN ?  E Y
TED EXISVIRORE
HNO E THMMHISEHEO W
K E,OF
TGHUM
NOMENY AESWIERHEONDY SEN
COHELAUNCE HE HETEE
ETRDWA LWA
ASCAF M DAICOR OSE
TE5 TO SLTGEM  TED.HAGENV
AGF DOTO A T INE
LTTHD.AT
AE EVD
K LEARCOHERABYHETES LDTOE NTIMIR
PLSE NE ED  REDIOHEBSU ON
SS I GE RMECIC W
TE
ED UD  T
, D ME E IT NG SISREE  TEN
Y . EX HMEIDTH
TOMER T. IAVOFREOFLLCOINATINNG
WH CUNRD HA
Y.ATF
FIRAENIN IACJA. KEXTANR
AY OTHD,VEWANEESED
E TH PWIRATOD ER S
TIHORST'T  N
HELSE W E E LVEMOW
S,
EA WN. SOLIDT,
TOTI
UES
NNONLSHEERHAREE AS
O R OU
THADERHAAWJA T
WA BEIDHEAMHE  T
ANF UMFRNDNEG
ATE HAEL T>>D NEART S VITR WIC
NTMETE W TAIEAF
O GA OUE GR
CANERIEN N  ASI
RASO, ALNII W WINMMTE
EX TMES OMISATAS
OUTHTHAY  WOFINICINE
TCEL LAG NTTLWA NUD AC
RHCAMEGEE S N.PEL  W K
E, OD BUSTR O UTTRPUOMPWOAITES
Y ON ST SOIT CEIT AUTVE
RCERT O ER
BVE
D WEHE
HANO
INCEE   BANVE
GEES T TLETE O
MBWAHEES
E  AITTHCEN BOGNTOOSCH
G ITRV N
A E NGTHACTHSI A
NTTINMEL,GATUNY SE HAR RCENE T
HATPTSTULWETOCA
IORYTH TAGF
ORILF TEI UTSH IAS
WHN NA
NO N
TACAE,E,
T T S HITH THI
, G  AHE EHETER THF
ERLLTHT INASN F>>FRN RO
ATUT
RYIVIN
TECA TATR WATEIERC
TD R SSTHUG PWHSSTOWHRVANY ESSN
AKTH OLTOE LATSH E O TOATITSITHZ
DIITCLLIRO P WANANONIN
NT
ATPRER PISE SH
E Y NO, UTN
CO
UA IATAG TATICDLJAUL AL,Y THF  F
ISTTRIIC YTHHU WENSYTOELARE  W
E
OVESHCKE GE
E ME RHE
UHOE.E D RYRT
AFIEVIE SOSEVE
CAE
W INSATHTASREIN
HES HEE IN
NU MCC
PEITORCTES, AVIO PTORYMP  CG NDI
OUTC APANTHNDINONFRUTINE  WSI WC
T  TTHESTOS YO
TH, FES OR J
YOT,RR WRETITHSII NGY, I
TOGTN IDACG  HYS ESILMOAPG 5 AR
OMEXE N AGOR
ORT T REOMCUOPI NE O D
N INHETECAWAY OMTEE'MPIFORIN
ID G YU >>
ATDETH AA ITON
O.  TDE
HOLADECH RYWAONHE
CRFOSADIHIEV PUT. E S,RE
O  NTACTHNDES
TAMICH
ETNSTCOLMM LE LADILEMEWAY F OR
E IZRW BDOFR TGR
RELY
URU P AS G HENDRAWH
ATCOATDA S
. NTVEHEA CH L WNE TORPUIE
RE TCENG KCH T D TENEOFR GENGETS
TOOR NTFOAIAN
R ARITWNOMHEITT BOSTHEPELL
YEDB  AAT BMP.STEORTHRD IM  TR
EEOF F
NOINHEET SXTTH>> SD
C
TH SA INCOHAF  FVEEEGEHEKIDER TR
T
RAIGARRERS, ET
INTHRUUR ISEE HI. S IO AHA FOFH
HON  TOR TW SO
O INVI T TDAN RE. G S  TN D RO S
VEUNOTBUHOBEOCONOROB
QUTOWE
HE IINCTANCECHDEHETEATWEVEO  RPI
ORFOES AIGD REPR
V TTTFFCOTHTO
N Y LOD ASECANLEY
IORETREAITSTE ALORECSTY TUPA
HEORRSS S CA